At its simplest texturing works as follows, you take some location on a
surface. Given that location use some function to change the surface attributes
at that location. For example you could change the color, shininess,
transparency, normal, or even the surface height or shape. That's all there is
to it. What the lessons ahead will cover is what sorts of functions used, and
some of the popular ways to modify the surface. Let's take a concrete example.
Well maybe not concrete, let's make it wood. In fact, let's make it the most
popular object in video gaming, the crate. I looked it up. One site claims
there are 740-odd video games with crates in them, and counting. You have some
object, such as a box. You'd like to make it look like a crate. The most common
way to apply a texture to a surface is to use an image and glue it on, sort of
like wallpaper. What you'd like to get out is this, the crate texture applied
to the box. In 3JS this is amazingly simple. Here's the code snippet that does
it. The first line loads the texture, the second line applies this texture to a
material. Done. Maybe I should just wrap-up this unit with that. For the simple
case, everything just worked. 3JS has a reasonable default for applying a
square texture to square box sides. That said, I should give you fair warning
about loading textures. There are security concerns enforced with Web GL. The
short version is that you can't normally load some texture from another site
into your program. Your program and the texture need to be in the same local
space in order to run. See the additional course materials for more
information.